je considère que le racisme n'a pas de
frontière
et que de fait le racisme c'est le rejet
de l'autre sur la base d'un préjugé donc
je considère que le rejet de l'autre et
les préjugés peuvent naître de part et
d'autre de toutes parts plus comment le
dire puisque on est sur des
déterminismes de couleur de peau et
la réalité c'est que je crois qu'il faut
pas tomber dans le piège de la
compétition des souffrances face à ce
que représentent leurs racines pour ceux
qui le subissent et je crois que c'est
un peu ce à quoi on a droit et c'est
dommage et il faut éviter le piège qu'on
a déjà connu dans des débats politiques
français sur la mémoire par exemple
puisqu'on a évoqué des pentes de la
mémoire et de l'histoire là aussi
notamment pas dans une compétition les
mémoires je dirais toutes les mémoires
sont respectables il faut les traiter
tout parce que le concerne au nom de la
sensibilité des liens culturels des
liens de famille de que les uns et des
autres moi je suis horrifié quand
j'entends dire on parle trop de la shoah
passé de l' esclavage on ne parle trop
de l'exclavage passé la colonisation
dont j'ai envie de dire il faut parler
de la shoah l'esclavagé de la
colonisation
quand on parle du racisme jamais de dire
il faut lutter contre le racisme qui
touche nos compatriotes d'origine
africaine donc de couleurs contre ceux
qui sont d'origine maghrébine et contre
ceux qui sont des franco français de
jeunes c'est comme un génération et qui
subissent le racisme il ya quand même de
différence la première c'est qu'il ya un
racisme qui peut être considéré comme un
racisme systémique il ya un racisme qui
peut être considéré comme un racines de
la vie quotidienne qui n'est pas moins
violent qui l'est tout autant mais qui
peut être été la même manière je crois
qu'il faut pas qu'on fasse preuve de
faiblesse ni d'indulgence face à ces
racisme quand on demande un emploi et
qu'on ait refusé au nom de son patronyme
parce qu'on s'appelle mohamed parce
qu'on voudrait que certaines va changer
de prénom c'est inadmissible c'est pas
la république c'est pas la france quand
on demande en logements et qu'on voit
sur logement revient parce qu'on
s'appelle mamadou c'est scandaleux ça
n'est pas la république ce n'est pas la
france mais quand on est traités de
sales blancs ou de sale français dans la
rue si on ne bouge pas c'est qu'on n'est
pas la république c'est qu'on n'est pas
la france donc moi je voudrais qu'on
cesse de tomber dans une sorte de
compétition où les zincs sur est victime
de racines puisque les autres ou nous
soyons tous sans pitié en cohésion
républicaine contre tous les racismes
voilà moi ma position elle éclaire l est
les ambiguïtés
[Applaudissements]